this week we've got frustrated slasher
fire reveal and crazy streaker mmm I
feel like we could name each of the who
would be what frustrated slasher David
sorry I feel like they're all David no
no fire fire reveal is Joe I think fire
reveal yeah and then crazy streaker
crazy streaker sorry I don't know you
David six years to see his but yeah what
and I and I and I dimly let it - yeah it
was possible very Hoffman Bart was here
he'd be a streaker yeah all week it's
always naked
something was streaking is this his
normal state of life just naked yeah I
feel like I would streak if I felt
better about my stomach like if I just
like lost a little bit of weight I would
be down a streak you better build that
pristine seat you know what it's like
yelling in a hurricane he does you
nothing you can know exactly if I just
got a little bender around my stomach
Vanessa go what like a little Bindo
what's a band oh my God look up in its a
it's like a strapless dad does what we
called the band no kids in school and we
made fun of them as they carry the
trombones yeah BAM yeah you're one yeah
a clarinet we finally met someone who
actually played the clarinet because
that's always been a thing I was like
who would play a bass a wise person well
I do plenty of girls are pretty clear
that's why I play clarinet yeah oh
that's pretty good
well that was getting you [ __ ] like
crazy right bro yeah yeah yeah they were
playing his Clara don't know what it
cleared it looks like no and then you
found out that the girls are so tired
from playing the clarinet they don't
want to sub dick any man it's the black
I should have picked the guitar girls I
thought that saxophone players were sexy
all right for a first story this woman
named Katherine she's 27 years old from
anyway anyway Ohio Florida Florida she's
from Florida and she has been charged
with aggravated battery with a deadly
weapon because she splashed her
boyfriend up all up in the face after he
kept declining declining her sexual
advances but he slashed him with what a
razor blade knife a knife because she
wanted to get some that doesn't turn men
on I tried all the way to my friend some
real sexual frustration Katherine holy
[ __ ]
she looks like she does [ __ ] Satya
well she looks like if she wore some
makeup to cover to yeah yeah yeah did
you or maybe she'd be pretty bad give us
a bucket dick yeah I think you know
something around the eyes look a little
touch-up around the eyes a little it
looks like she got to a fight with him
he punched her both in the other she
looks like she's just like a character
in a Tim Burton movie you win more flies
with honey I feel like we look alike no
yeah you do it's like your evil sister
oh yeah oh my god it's it's a motive
yeah if you're Vaughn absolutely what
the eyebrows though but you don't have
the Saudi circles around your eyes like
circles but not like Saudi nude look I
took my makeup off which is not it's not
even that shit's like before you put on
a Batman mask you know they take you're
way hotter what are you talking about -
oh they you don't need a knife
yeah we're gonna move on now nobody
needs a knife to bone tip yeah you don't
need to take out a knife to get to get
some do you tell them that's that's a
crazy libido I know isn't that crazy but
she was saying that she so when her
boyfriend went home she said he already
had slashes all over his face okay that
just happens yeah and then fell on a
bush purpose so he was saying like yeah
I got home she was drunk she kept
wanting a [ __ ] I kept saying no she went
to the kitchen grabbed a large silver
knife and then she like threw the knife
at me and like out of space and then
just like hip slash so she blacked out
or something she's like I woke up and he
had nine slashes all over what does he
look like how hot is this man yeah
demanding that dick how do we know that
she that she's guilty we should believe
all women at all times guys Steve
getting a deep-water all right getting
into I've always believed that women
always I do I do believe her I see
I might go to hell but I'm just like you
just should've gave him her some dick
man [ __ ] dick or dad say you're gonna
withhold like that you're gonna get cut
bigger badder put bad ass to sleep cuz
that [ __ ] is crazy man for me I know
cuz I'm just like I'm thinking about my
safety and if I know how [ __ ] crazy
my girlfriend is I will dick her down
learn knock the [ __ ] out and I'm running
away that's good just [ __ ] just lay
there and have a boner and just have her
do the work yeah yeah but maybe he gets
all turned off because I'm pretty she is
just got just lay there there's like
what people say sex is exhausting you
just lay there what if sex ever did love
it cuz like I'll fall asleep and I'll
wake up
I think we can cut I feel relaxed as she
feels very unsatisfied you're lucky Mary
oh so lucky I know you guys all have sex
there's like a missing part of this
story I bet you like they [ __ ] already
five times and then this is 15 minutes
later he can't [ __ ] anymore and then she
gets crazy I mean he didn't say that I
mean she's already crazy it doesn't
matter if it was before the first book
or after the fifth how do we know that
she's crazy how do you know how do you
know a nice part yeah how do we know it
don't try to [ __ ] me and I got him with
the night and that's not crazy but it's
like he wouldn't [ __ ] me so I [ __ ]
that's a lion cuddle he says that he
came home with scratches on her face I
believe the woman told the story there
both sides here so they're both saying
that this happened well yeah well no no
she's saying that he came home with this
but she didn't messenger because she's a
woman you weren't listening see I think
I think the guy's telling nothing that
even huh see I think I think the guy's
telling the truth and here's the reason
why no guy would admit it's very hard
for a guy to admit that she stabbed my
face cuz I wouldn't [ __ ] her well yeah
that's why guys won't admit that they
got raped yeah like legit that's why
guys won't come forth with it yes
because it's shameful because if they
got raped by a woman that's why and they
don't want to be made fun of that's why
but then in this case I could clearly
tell he was afraid for his life yeah cuz
I'd say it I'd be like man I would have
[ __ ] she try to kill me first
she got my dick part then she put my
dick inside of her it's like always
you're a trendy hot llama child yeah I
feel like I'm just shooting threes baby
this is so i disavow next story great my
manga is not funny you may be about five
great I'll tell you right now it is
legitimately that seat because he is
turning in the part right
this desk hey it ain't the desk it's the
man maybe the desk it's all me let me
take over from here baby
also we can't ignore that Joe started a
sentence with I may go to hell for this
but at least I recognized it before I
say it
that's a good man Oh would dick town us
girlfriend oh that's a good man right
next sorry good man that's a good man
it's all about survival
you don't need a dick town anybody all
right she just needs to [ __ ] down you
all right how about that I have no shame
I did reviews and I was I was choked out
jiu-jitsu style because I refuse to give
dick wait when was this this girl was
mess around we weren't even officially
dating but then she was crazy
[Laughter]
that's so interesting
we had a jiu-jitsu match in the middle
of the living room and my roommates were
watching this [ __ ] because she kept
saying I want some big was she drunk
kind of here we go
oh please when I'm done with that story
this dude who for some reason the media
felt it was very important to mention
his occupation so he looked Border
Patrol agent he was ordered to pay two
hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
fines after starting a 47 acre wildfire
in Arizona 47 acres and this was all
because he did it during a gender-reveal
celebration for his wife's pregnancy oh
so what he was like read for girl right
I'm gonna [ __ ] burn this tree no boy
this was it a misfire like he open one
of those cans in that [ __ ] no so he
shot a target containing ten or eight oh
my god did leave your explosives that
substance and then that started the fire
and it quickly spread
7,000 acres what was it a boy or girl
Oh 47 thousand acres it required 800
firefighters and it cost more than 8
million dollars to fight oh my god to
move out of their house did you is that
a [ __ ] lumber mill like what the [ __ ]
47,000 that's literally a whole forest
that's like all of Arizona's trees does
he just sit there during it in his
wife's oh you are such an idiot
exactly like he can never call his wife
stupid em no never
so you're so stupid really 47,000 acres
like how stupid am i compared to the
forty-seven thousand acres that you blew
up you know what though that the fine
that he paid honestly I would want to
pay more than that fine if I was the
person who did it would you feel that
bad I don't feel really bad and just let
my rest my life I would just give money
he killed 48 grizzly bears so you know
what you know what would be fair is he
becomes a park ranger and for the rest
of his life he plants trees can't plant
that man it'll be like Johnny Appleseed
and [ __ ] we'll call them like Hector the
pine tree or so got it I know what a
half acre lot looks like it's [ __ ]
great how old is he how old is he I mean
what does the name is Dennis and he's 37
years okay yeah we'll call him Dennis
the Menace
yeah this Dennis the Menace it is the
Sequoia man I mean Dennis the Menace
would like break a window with a rock
you know like this guy's like this has a
wheat plant every day walk around well
it's a great fit in Arizona yeah so I'm
imagine it was like that Drive you know
what's a trip though they have forests
at the north side of their state yeah
yeah kind of feel for him because one
time when I was a kid I'm sure yeah you
guys started fires in your own like in
people's yards before no I [ __ ]
thank you so he burned down a whole
building one time yeah
Oh what Hey when he was a kid he said
what story Minnie did time I one time I
was having a party and then like we were
kids we didn't know how to start a fire
so we started a fire but then we were
like how do we make it bigger so we
poured gasoline on it just for just a
fire yeah but we're kids so that but
then we started blowing up and then and
then kids more my friends was like and
just running around holding the gasoline
but then I kind of feel I don't feel for
the guy what I feel for him because like
in that situation what do you do
we're the parents I love people I don't
know we ran those not a good so you
started a fire than you ran you don't
feel bad for this man you're really bad
got away with that [ __ ]
you should feel awful for this guys your
birthday I wish I could give money to
the parents right Ned okay go ahead do
it we're gonna watch you yeah bud speech
you don't get better donate now to five
years in prison you will have to pay 100
thousand dollars in restitution when
sentence and the remaining 120 thousand
dollars in fines will be paid in
installments of $500 each month for the
next twenty [ __ ] deal dude I can't
bite trees that cheap at Home Depot bro
and five years one dollar and Sony eight
cents a tree that's how we budgeted it a
lot of prisoners if they want reduce
time and all that stuff too they can
fight forest fires that's true my cousin
know that I'm not doing I'm not doing
this cleanup and whatever yeah Oh
cleanup is fine but finding forest fires
that well it's both they couldn't
probably do it is boring in prison I bet
forest fires are [ __ ] frightening
give it as hot as [ __ ] out there it's
already hot then attacks huh my god we
didn't go to prison but he was like in
juvie kind of stuff I mean like they
gave him that option she would fight
yeah it's like community service stuff
last story here
so that was this naked man chasing
people around a chick-fil-a parking lot
demanding that they look at his dick and
if they don't or if they do than that
they're gay
is he in seventh grade they're gay if
they don't anti-gay if they do I like
this guy guess where Zig please Florida
yep good guess
look at my dick you gay hey look at my
dick oh you don't want to get that
girl's boyfriend that has slashes on her
face she said look at my penis look at
my penis they're gay how old is he he's
a seventh grade not that funny but being
a 30 year old yeah being a full grown
man in doing this so was he doing it for
a bit or was he like on quaaludes I mean
it seemed like he was poor bath salts
you're like he's asking men and women
yeah anyway so he's calling women gay
for looking at his life yeah that's
pretty good yeah but they're saying that
there's this one witness that her
boyfriend called her at around 1:15 a.m.
and he's like you got to come see this
dick he was right II he keep is riding
his bike home from work but then he had
to tell her that that was his naked guy
chasing her chasing him on foot and then
finally like he like it was just like he
was just fixated on that girl's
boyfriend and he he kept continuing to
chase him until you reach that
chick-fil-a and then that's when he just
started telling people around like a
penis okay so I thought it was a
chick-fil-a thing cuz chick-fil-a has
had like anti-gay stances so it's
nothing to do with dad your deepest [ __ ]
I did not be better at all all I do is
dig I was trying to find out the answer
no he's just a guy on crack man I know
this guy's name is Corey when people
does what he looks like
oh when yeah when people are really on
drugs or whatever man they get so
creative dude so creative yeah they have
some good bit sometimes yeah like how do
you even come up with that I'm gonna get
naked I think it's all their
subconscious it's like as if a dream is
talking you know and you're in a dream
and it's like while I was talking to a
chick
monka and then it turned it to Elvis
Presley and then but he was teaching me
things that my dad taught me because you
know it's like everything that happens
in your dreams comes out their mouth in
reality it's like Inception but real
life yeah it's just like living it have
you ever had some very creative ideas
when you used to be on drugs not like
this well I just don't remember but I
don't remember doing some crazy [ __ ]
like this or like being lost in the load
and then like calling people gay you
take the right drugs you didn't take the
right yeah I think that's what it is
maybe I didn't go far deep enough it was
crazy that [ __ ] Mariel doesn't like
chick-fil-a [ __ ] insane you know what
blows my mind is I didn't think anybody
would not like okay like you could be
like vegans vegans but she [ __ ]
doesn't like it she doesn't think it's
good why she'd think it's good I think
it's good I almost broke up with her
what does she think is good
I thought she'd think everything's good
that's why I thought too but she doesn't
like shake shake it
she hates shake chef she just gave us
room oh I know why cuz a price
no she just she had it I love that oh I
know exactly what I think he's like no
taste well where does he eat it in LA Oh
David I know probably didn't have it
with the sauces right maybe she doesn't
like good ingredients like I don't
understand why you wouldn't I understand
if it's like oh it's okay
I'll stand there but you can say you
don't like it like she hates it strong
stance does she talk I'm in a black
mirror episode yeah wait what does she
weigh she doesn't like chick-fil-a what
does she like that [ __ ] no does she
like McDonald's er I've always hated
bacon and everyone's like how the [ __ ] I
can understand why you don't like bacon
bacon strong it's very strong and it
depends on how it's made
I like things but people go crazy when I
say that and like you know it's greasy
it's like yeah it tastes super salty and
they're like what about this turkey
bacon like it doesn't matter what animal
I don't like it doesn't taste good I
don't
the taste of it it's really salty sounds
like flimsy - it's like either too
flimsy when she does she like in and out
she likes even though she loves him
enough maybe that's it cuz I like both
there's nothing wrong with I like Paul's
what's he'll expensive though
once I had Shake Shack though I had to
go turn my back line you know have you
had to have it
I tweet we check we turn our back on in
and out when we had have it habits good
and they have a lot of options and they
don't Acula french fries like like you
know knocked us and on some garbage
garbage take off my shirt and fight you
right now you have the good fries and
also I would take off my outdoor right
now his next level you have to have 11
ranches in and out though you just got
to eat the fries within the 10 seconds
that it was yes sure I don't like the
taste it's like you just taste like
potatoes came out of like raw potatoes
okay that look french fries are America
now pal that means it's french fries
have to have all kind of [ __ ] on them
that's true like McDonald's tastes likes
David they taste like potatoes has to be
refried mashed potatoes if you think
that a french fry needs to be close to
the real potato you're out of your
[ __ ] potato then potato 32 pity the
baked potato with no salt you see the
walk out of my french fries I love it
now french fries I love
[Music]